cinq bus avec à leur bord une petite
centaine de personnes qui ont été
évacuées de mario paul dont 69 du
complexe d'azov talent ce sont des
visages pâles des regards vides des
silhouette frêle marqué par ces deux
mois que ces personnes ont passé dans ce
complexe d'azov talent les témoignages
sont
extrêmement frappant ce sont des
témoignages glaçant qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de résumer en
quelques phrases on nous a parlé de ses
murs qui tremblent est à longueur de
journée à cause des bombardements de ces
températures glaciales du manque de
nourriture d'eau d'électricité on nous a
parlé de ces femmes de ses enfants dont
certains qui étaient en bas âge certains
n'avaient même pas plus d'un an et demi
on a également parlé du rôle qu'ont joué
les soldats qui cuisinait parfois pour
tous ses citoyens prise au piège mais
d'autres fois il fallait se débrouiller
tout seul et c'est ce qu'a essayé de
faire ce jeune homme que je vous propose
d'écouter
nous avions quelques rations
alimentaires et quelques boîtes de
conserves
de temps séparés on en mangeait le père
est parti parce qu'on a été pendant deux
mois
c'était pareil pour l'eau voile intégral
je vois des jeunes hommes convient
d'écouter qui n'a 27 ans fait figure
d'exception puisque ce qu'on avait il ya
c'est surtout des femmes et des enfants
les hommes qui ont plus de 18 ans n'ont
pas eu le temps il de l'autorisation de
venir a jusqu'ici à zaporijia à
l'exception des hommes ou des jeunes qui
souffrent de maladies chroniques